[موسيقى]
البلاد من تبعات هذه الاجواء المشحونه مع
ترد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه اهلا
بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم في فصل جديد من فصول الازمه
السياسيه في تونس تتصاعد نبره السلطه ضد
المعارضه ونبره المعارضه ضد السلطه ما
يفاقم حاله الصراع التي باتت مفتوحه بين
الرئيس وبعض الاحزاب السياسيه من جهه وبين
الرئيس والاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل من
جهه اخرى
لمعرفه مالاتي هذا التصعيد بين كل هذه
الاطراف
وتداعياتها المحتمله على المشهد السياسي
في البلاد يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه
الحلقه من تونس رياض الشعيبي المستشار
السياسي لرئيس حركه النهضه والقياده بجبهه
الخلاص المعارضه وليد العباسي القيادي في
حزب التيار الشعبي والمهدي المبروك استاذ
علم الاجتماع في الجامعه التونسيه والوزير
السابق فاهلا بهم جميعا
الصراع الحالي بين السلطه والمعارضه ليس
وليد اللحظه بل نتيجه تراكمات اتخذت
اشكالا مختلفه من مراسيما وقرارات اصدرها
الرئيس قيس سعيد منذ نحو عامين نذكر
بابرزها في هذا التسلسل الزمني للاحداث
منذ الخامس والعشرين من يوليو تموز 2021
[موسيقى]
وبعد هذه المراسيم والقرارات التي اصدرها
سعيد جاءت حمله الاعتقالات التي صبت مزيدا
من الزيت على لهيب الازمه السياسيه ورفعت
منسوب الاحتقان والاستقطاب في الشارع لكن
ذلك لم يمنع الرئيس من المضي في اصدار
مزيد من القرارات اخرها حلوا جميع المجالس
البلديه المنتخبه عام 2018 قبل شهرين فقط
من انتخابات كان يفترض ان تجري التجديدها
الى جانبيه نص اخر
يتعلق
بحل المجالس البلديه كلها هذا احدث فصول
التحول في المشهد السياسي التونسي المضطرب
قريبا مجالس منتخبات اخرى يشملها قرار
الحل بامر رئاسي ولا تسال المسيره مستمره
امام وزراء الحكومه قال الرئيس سعيد
المعركه على من عاثوا في البلاد فسادا
ستستمر بالقوه نفسها وبالعزم نفسه حتى
يستعيد الشعب التونسي امواله وحقوقه وفي
ذلك دلاله على ان المشهد الصدامي بين
الرئيس ومعارضيه ماضي نحو مزيد من التصعيد
ففي طليعه المفسدين كما ذكر في خطابه
اولئك الذين كانوا يدعون الى محاربه
الفساد وهم اليوم يتظاهرون بكل حريه تحت
حمايه الامن حسب قوله
ليعارضوا سياسات الرئيس
لا يبدو في الافق مخرج قريب من هذا النفق
المظلم فحركوا المعارضه في الشارع يحافظ
على زخمه تاره من جانب الاحزاب السياسيه
وتاره من الاتحاد التونسي للشغل وبينما
تستمر هذه المظاهرات الممدده بما تصفهم
انقلاب الرئيس على مؤسسات الدوله المنتخبه
يقول سعيد انه احترم المواعيد الدستوريه
سواء بصيغه الدستور او تنظيم الاستفتاء او
تنظيم انتخابات اعضاء مجلس نواب الشعب
وتلك انتخابات انتهت دورتها الثانيه شهر
يناير الماضي الى ما انتهت اليه نسبه
مشاركه ضعيفه وغير مسبوقه لم تتجاوز 11%
جعلت معارضيه يرفضون الاقرار باي شرعيه
للبرلمان الجديد
يضاف الى ذلك اصرار السلطه على ملاحقه
معارضين من الصف الاول
يتهمهم الرئيس بالتامر على امن الدوله
والوقوف وراء ازمات توزيع السلع وارتفاع
الاسعار بينما تصر المعارضه على مطلب
الافراج عن هؤلاء المعتقلين السياسيين
وتقول ان سعيد يستغل سلطته ويضغط على
القضاء لافتعال قضايا فارغه في حقهم
تتسارع هذه الاحداث بينما يزداد ثقل
الازمه الاقتصاديه في البلد الذي يقف على
حافه الافلاس فقد علق البنك الدولي مؤقتا
مناقشات الشراكه والتعاون مع تونس للفتره
الممتده بين العام الحالي وعام 2027 بسبب
ما وصفه بتصاعد الاعتداءات في حق
المهاجرين الافارقه بدوافع عنصريه في هذا
البلد
يوسع ذلك دائره المازق الذي مس التونسيين
في قوتهم وينذر بالاسوا في ظل غياب اي
نقاط تلاقي بين السلطه والمعارضه
[تصفيق]
نجدد الترحيب بضيوفنا الثلاثه ونبدا
بالسيد وليد العباسي القيادي في حزب
التيار الشعبي ونبدا باخر التطورات
والمتعلقه بحل الرئيس قيس سعيد لكل
المجالس البلديه المنتخبه
كيف رايتم مثل هذا القرار
تحياتي سيدي الكريم وتحيه لضيوفك الكرام
بدايه اعتقد ان المجالس البلدي مجالس
البلديه يعني هي ستنتهي عهدتها في مايل
مقبل ولا نعتقد ان الدوله التونسيه اليوم
قادر تنظيم هذه الانتخابات انتخابات
البلديه لتجديد المجالس البلديه بطريقه
جيده وبطريقه يعني سلسه وسليمه وهو ما
يفترض قبل ذلك ان يكون لنا قانون
الانتخابي وان يتم الاعداد الجيد
للانتخابات بلديه جديده بقانون انتخابي
جديد يقطع مع القانون السابق الذين اعتقد
ان فيه ثغرات وفيه النات كبرى استقر رائر
رئاسه الجمهوريه على ان يتم حل
المجالس البلديه وتعويضها بنيابات خصوصيه
تعمل الى حدود تعيين يعني محطه الانتخابيه
القادمه وتعد الدوله لها بشكل بالشكل جيد
اعتقد ان هذا القرار ليس يعني غريبا وهو
متوقع حتى
خصوم ربما مسار 25 جويليه وخصوم رئاسه
الجمهوريه كانوا ينتظرون هذا القرار لعده
لعده اعتبارات اعتقد انه لن يغير شيئا في
المسار وليس بالنقطه المفصليه والنقطه
المهمه على اعتبار انه كما قلتم في ميل
مقبل تنتهي عهده هذه المجالس البلديه ما
يجب ان تقوم به رئاسه الجمهوريه وما يشبه
يقوم به يعني مجلس النواب بالمنتخب هو
الاعداد الجيد لقانون الانتخابي يقطع مع
الثغرات التي كانت في القانون الانتخابي
السابق يقطع مع تسلل
المتحيلين وتسلل يعني المهربين وتسلل
المجرمين للبلديات ويبني لنا مجالس بلديه
قريبه فعليا من استحقاقات المحليه للشعب
التونسي ربما ليس هذا وجهه نظر المعارضه
السيد رياض شعيبي
مساء الخير هو منذ قليل فقط وقع نشر الامر
الذي يدعو للانتخابات البلديه ويحل
المجالس ويحدد شروط الترشح لهذه المجالس
والملاحظات الاوليه هو اقصاء كل الذين
كانوا يشتغلون كاعضاء ورؤساء للبلديات
خلال الدوره السابقه بالتالي واضح الاقصاء
السياسي
ومحاوله
تكريس صوت واحد ولون واحد في الانتخابات
القادمه هذا التوجه ليس غريب وليس جديد
فمنذ 25 جويليه على الاقل 2021 كل
المراسيم والاوامر والتوجهات السياسيه
للسلطه تجرم المعارضه وتحاول ان تعزلها
وتحاول ان تقصيها في عديد من المحطات
وتتراجع شيئا فشيئا عن كل ما تحقق خلال
عشريه الانتقال الديمقراطي واليوم جاء
الدور على اللامركزيه والتراجع على هذا
التوجه الاستراتيجي الكبير الذي ارصته
ثوره الحريه والكرامه بالدفع نحو اقامه
نوع من اللامركزيه في اداره الشان المحلي
هناك توجه الان لاعاده مركز السلطه
وللتخلص من كل المجالس المنتخبه بل واكثر
حتى من هذا خلق مناخ وايجاد شروط
غير ديمقراطيه
لتصعيد
مجالس جديده في انتخابات قادمه هذه
المجالس مضمونه الولاء لرئيس الدوله
ويستطيع التصرف في هذه المجالس وفق ما
يراه طبعا هذه ليست الا خطوه جديده من
الخطوات التي تسلكها السلطه في اطار
التراجع عن الديمقراطيه كما قلت الذي بدنا
نشده منذ اكثر من سنه ونصف هو حتى بعيدا
عن راي المعارضه الدكتور مهدي مبروك
ردود الفعل التي تابعناها في تونس كانت
غاضبه في مجملها حتى ان البعض اعتبر ان
هذا هو تفكيك لكل المؤسسات الدوله وبدايه
تركيز نظام فاشي شعبوي هذا على الاقل وفق
تعبير السيد حسام الحامي منسق عام ائتلاف
صمود كيف يمكن ان ينظر الى هذه الخطوه
بعيدا عن تجاذبات المعارضه والموالاه
شكرا لك يا سي محمد على الدعوه والشكر
ايضا لضيوفك الكرام واعتقد انك انتهيت
بجمله بليغه مفادها ان ائتلاف صمود يصف ما
يحصل بانه فشيع علما وان ائتلاف صمود كان
الحاضنه الاولى ل 25 اجو الى حينئذ وهذا
دليل اخر على ان من احتضن 25 الان ينفضون
من حوله اعتقد ان المعركه هي معركه رمزيه
والسيد رئيس الجمهوريه يخوض معركه رمزيه
عناوينه الكبرى واضحه العنوان الاول هو
التفكيك منظومه الانتقال الديمقراطيه على
ارتباكه وعلى علاته هنا اذا هو يخرج تماما
من سرديه الانتقال الديمقراطي الى سلبيه
التاسيس وبالتالي هو قد اجهض على اخر
تمثيليه
ديمقراطيه
للانتقال الديمقراطي بعد ان حل مجلس
النواب حل الحكومه يعني وذهب في ايضا
تفكيك كافه الهيئات الدستوريه الى الى غير
حنا اذا اخر
هيكل او اخر هيئه منتخبه في مسار الانتقال
الديمقراطي خلال العشره القارطه هو
البلديات وبالتالي الان كما قلت يدق
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه مسمار يعني اتحاد في
هذا الامر الثاني هو ايضا واعتقد انه رمزي
بالاساس هو ان هذه النخب كلها والسيد رئيس
الجمهوريه الى حد الان لم يستعمل مطلقا
لفظ النخبه المحليه واعتقد ان احدى اركان
الديمقراطيه التشاركيه التي عشناها الى
غريرك استنادا الى النص المرجعي المتعلق
بالجماعات العموميه والمحليه هو انشاء شيء
نسميه يعني ان نقبل المحليه وتفكيك
المركزيه المطلقه التي طبعت الدوله
التونسيه منذ
استقلالها حينئذ هذه النخام كما قلت ودليل
ذلك ان اقصى النخب كما يقول السيد الرئيس
يقول عفوا ملوثه وبالتالي هي حينئذ يلحقها
تماما بان نخب السياسيه والنخب الحقوقيه
والنخب البرلمانيه يضع كل هذا ضمن هذا
العنوان الكبير وهو فساد النخب المعركه
كما قلت معركه رمزيه والسيده رئيس يخلق
حاله من التصحر الثقافي من اجل استنبات
كما قلت نخبيه بين نخبه التابعه لهذا
المشروع كما قلت المشروع الشعب والذي بدا
ينحرف بالمسار الديمقراطي الى حاله من
التصلب المشكله سيد وليد العباسي ان رئيس
الدوله تقريبا لم يترك اي هيئه منتخبه الا
وحلها البرلمان مجلس الاعلى للقضاء الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات هيئه مكافحه
الفساد حتى ان رسما كاريكاتوريا اطلعت
عليه اليوم بالصدفه في احد المواقع
التونسيه يقول الهيئه المؤسسه الوحيده
التي لم يحلها الرئيس رغم انها منتخبها هي
رئاسه الجمهوريه هل يمكن ان يتواصل هذا
النسق في التعامل مع الدوله
هو يعني كما قلت بالضبط هو نسق هو يعني
تهديد ما بني خلال عشر سنوات الماضيه
تهديد منظومه الربيع العربي منظومه حركه
النهضه وحلفائها منظومه الديمقراطيه
المغشوشه والديمقراطيه الشكليه منظومه
الريع السياسي والريع المالي والريع
الاقتصادي منظومه الفساد منظومه تجير
الدوله التونسيه لصالح لصالح تحالفات
دوليه ومحابر دوليه بعينها هذا ما ارادته
25 جويليه وبما باعتبار نحن كجزء من 25
جويليه نعتقد ان بناء نظام سياسي جديد كان
امرا ضروريا بنا نظام سياسي مبني على
دستور جديد يقطع مع تشتت السلطه التنفيذيه
الذي رايناه وحاله الاحتراب الدائمه بين
رئاسه الجمهوريه ورائس الحكومه اعاده
الاعتبار
رئاسه الجمهوريه ليكون لنا مسؤول واضح
يحاسبه الشعب التونسي القطع مع
الديمقراطيه الشكليه والتوجه نحو
الديمقراطيه شعبيه
حقيقيه والقطع مع الريع السياسي الاعتبار
ان شاهدنا شخصيات دون سواها يعني وكانه
انتهت
الرجال ونساء السياسه في تونس ما عدا
مجموعات خاصه كذلك نريد القطع مع التدخل
الخارجي في العمليه السياسيه في الداخل
وكل هذا يتطلب ضربا لكل ما بني في السابق
وبناء نظام سياسي جديد يريده الشعب
التونسي على انقاذ هذا النظام السياسي
قوامه السياده الوطنيه اولا واخيرا
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه بديلا عن ديموقراطيه
المغشوشه وديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيه الهستيريا صناديق الانتخابيه
ومبنيه على عداله اجتماعيه والتنميه
مستقله حقيقيه اعتقد ان
الصراع ومحور الصراع هو هذا دوله اخرى
نريدها دوله التونسيين لا دوله كما يرغب
فيها حلفاء
الخارج الذي يريدون السيطره ويريدون
العوده بكل الطرق الى الحكم رغما عن الشعب
الشعب التونسي الشعب التونسي نعتقد انه
قال كلمته هذه كما يسميها البعض نخبه
سياسيه اثبتت فشلها بل اثبتت فسادها
واثبتت حتى عملتها في التعاطي مع الخارج
لذلك عليها ان ترحل ويجب الفتح الباب
امامه التونسيات والتونسيين الخيريه الذين
يريدون النهوض ببلادهم ولهم مصلحه في
التغيير في تونس المشكله ان بنامه تسميه
بنظام سياسي جديد وهنا اسهل سيد رياض
الشعيبي ياتي ليس في سياق اجماع وطني ليس
في سياق مسار تشاركي وانما في سياق احادي
وفي نفس الوقت في ظل
مناخ سياسي متازم حمله الاعتقالات وهنا
نريد ان نتوقف عند حمله الاعتقالات اين
يمكن ان تصل لان الكل يتحدث عن ان الملفات
فارغه وان هناك ضرب كبير للاجراءات بشكل
غير مسبوق لا في عهد بن علي ولا في عهد
بورقيبه
المشكل استاذ محمد هو انه الخطاب الذي
نسمعه من هذه السلطه ومن انصارها هو نفس
الخطاب الذي تردده كل الديكتاتوريات في
التاريخ بالتالي ليس هناك شيء جديد
خطبتنا به السلطه او او اضافه نوعيه
قدمتها على مستوى الخطاب السياسي اتهام كل
المعارضين بالخيانه وبالفساد وباللا وطنيه
هذا هو نفس العبارات ونفس المصطلحات التي
تستعملها كل الديكتاتوريات في العالم لذلك
هذا الخطاب الدمغوجي وهذا الخطاب الشعبوي
لم يعد يمتلي اليوم على احد والحديث باسم
الشعب معيارنا الوحيد فيه هو المشاركه في
الانتخابات الاخيره التي لم تتجاوز 10% من
عموم الناخبين وبالتالي ما عاد باستطاعه
هذه السلطه ان تتحدث باسم الشعب بعد هذه
المشاركه الضعيفه هذا فضلا على ان رئيس
الدوله اليوم يعمل على
دعني اقول ان يجعل من نفسه السلطه الاصليه
لذلك البرلمان ينبثق عن ارادته وكذلك
المجالس الاقاليم التي يريد ان يرسيها يجب
ان تنبع عن ارادته وفق القانون الانتخابي
الذي يضعه حتى البرلمان الذي وقع انتخابه
لم يعطيه صلاحيه سن القانون الانتخابي كما
درجه كل الديمقراطيات في العالم
واستبق اجتماع هذا البرلمان
وانعقاد اعماله اصدار القانون الانتخابي
الذي سينظم انتخابات الاقاليم وهذا لتكريس
نفسه كسلطه اصليه بالنسبه للاعتقالات
الاخيره لو تسمح بالنسبه للاعتقالات
الاخيره طبعا هذا ايضا يدخل في اطار
محاوله تصفيه الخصوم واقصائهم لانه
الاعتقالات الاخيره شملت مجموعه من
الناشطين السياسيين الذين كانوا يجتمعون
لمحاوله تنظيم حوار سياسي بين العائلات
السياسيه وبين الاحزاب السياسيه
للخروج برؤيه مشتركه حول كيفيه الخروج من
الازمه الشامله التي تواجهها البلاد في
ابعادها السياسيه وفي ابعادها الاقتصاديه
ان يقع تجريم عمل المعارضه وان يقع تجريم
هذه المبادره فذلك مؤشر خطير جدا على
الانحراف الكبير الذي سلكته السلطه وخاصه
في المده الاخيره المشكله انك اشرت الى ما
سميته خطاب التخوين وخطاب التقسيم المشكله
انها كان ذلك حكر تقريبا على رئيس الدوله
الان انضم وزير الداخليه وزير الداخليه
التونسي توفيق شرف الدين قال ان المعارضين
يعرفون صدق رئيس الجمهوريه لكنهم لا
يريدون انسانا صادقا ووطنيا الوزير وصف
احزابا ورجال اعمال واعلاميين ونقابيين
وصفهم بالمرتزقه والخونه الذين باعوا
الوطن وتحالفوا ضد الشعب
يعرفوا الحقيقه يعرفوا صدق عديد العديد
المسؤولين
ويعرف صدق الجمهوريه
ولكنهم لا يريدون انسان صادق لا يريد ان
وطني لانه ما يساعدهم ناس يبيعوا
انسان ما يبيعش وما يجريش قلبه الناس الكل
وكيما يقول
حزب واحد كان يعني فيه شعب اصبح هناك واحد
رجال اعلام
رجال الاعمال بائع الوطن
نقابيين باعوا الوطن احزاب باعوا الوطن
هي نكبه سياسيه
حلفو جميعا ضد الشعب التونسي
صحيح
انهم خونه
الوزير اضاف انه اذا كانت هناك اخطاء
فادونيسيون هم من صنعها بخيانتهم
وارتزاقهم وفق تعبيرهم داعيا اياهم الى
الاصطفاف خلف الرئيس
اذا كان ثمه اخفاء ومشاكل يعيشها شعب
التونسي فتوانسه
وارتزاقنا وراء الخارج والاجنبي ولكن وراء
المال باي باي مصدر كان كان هذا الكل
يتنحى ونرجعوا للصدق والوطنيه نستلهم
الوطنيه
بكثير على كل مره اخرى
التفوا حول السيد الرئيس انها حرب دروس
انها حرب ضروس انها حرب غروس
دكتور مهدي المبروك انها حرب دروس انها
حرب دروس انها حرب دروس تقريبا هذا ربما
اخطر تصريح لوزير تونسي في الاشهر الماضيه
بعد استعمال الرئيس الدوله لكلمه حرب
تحرير وطني وزير الداخليه يتحدث عن حرب
دروس هذا المنطق في النقاش السياسي وفي
الجدل السياسي كيف تراه
انا اعتقد انه يفترض في وزاره الداخليه ان
تكون حاميه لكل التونسيين بقطع النظر عن
مواقفهم واختلافاتهم حتى ولو اختلفوا مع
الصيد الرئيس ولكن كما قلت هذا الخطاب
خطاب مؤسف للاسف لانه
كنا نتمنى كنا نتمنى يعني هذه العشريه ان
نحسم كتونسيين تماما
مساله يعني الامن الجمهوري
وقضيه انه
القضاء هو الفيصل وان يعني ذوي شبهه لهم
ولكن للاسف نعود كما قلت الى مربع
البيانات مربع الاستبداد الذي يجعل من
الامن كما قلت هو فرثا رئيسيا وهو يعني
هاته الاله الكبيره التي تحصي كما قلت
انفاس الناس وتفرز من هو الوطني ومن هو
الخائن الى احنا اذا كان يفترض كما قلت
ولا اعتقد انه احدا احدا يناقشني في اهميه
كما قلت حياد المؤسسه الامنيه جمهوريه
جمهوريه الامن الى غير ذلك طبعا سيكون
البعض يعني لم يكن الامن خلال العشر سنوات
ولكن اعتقد انه هذا التصريح حقيقه كما قلت
يضعنا امام امام حيره ان كان ان كنا نحن
تماما بعد 25 جويليه بصدد بناء امن جمهوري
ولذلك كما قلت اعتقد انه هذا التصريح قد
يكون قلت عتبه
جديد
بمقتضى البلاد شيئا فشيئا في نفق مظلم
يعني لم السيد رئيس الجمهري حينما يتحدث
عن دوله القانون والى غير هيك نبدو نبدو
الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى عن دوله القانون
دوله المؤسسات الامن الجمهوري وكل الاشياء
الذي حلمنا بها اعطيك مثال الان يعني
تقريبا اربعين الجمعيه بمختلف طيفها تندد
كما قلت بمثل هذه التصريحات اعتقد ان
السيد حمل وقد كان حليفا لحزب التيار
الشعبي الان يقف موقفا اخر المساله ليست
مع الفساد ومع العشريه ومع الديمقراطيه
ومع الاسلام السياسي الى ذلك المساله في
اعتقاد الفرزه الحقيقي الذي يقع الان هو
هذه هذين المخيمين الكبيرين مخيم
الديمقراطيه على اخطائها وعلاتها وامكانيه
اصلاحها وطبعا مخيم كبير للاسف ايضا هو
مخيم الشعبويه والانحراف عن الديمقراطيه
انتم سيد وليد العباسي
كحزب التيار الشعبي المؤيد للرئيس قيس
سعيد الا تزعجكم هذا لا يزعجكم هذا النوع
من التصريح الذي ياتي اصلا على خلفيه
متوتره يعني خطاب السلطه كله سواء رئيس
الدوله والان التحق به وزير الداخليه خطاب
توتير دائم وخطاب تحريض دائم وخطاب تعبئه
حربيه
كيف تنظرون الى الى الى مناخ من هذا
القبيل
بدايه نعتقد ان الفرز في تونس لن يكون
فرزا على قاعده من مع 25 جويليه ومن مع ضد
خمسه ضد 25 جويليه بل نعتقد ان الفرز
الحقيقي هو فرز وطني بامتياز اعتقد ان
خندقا اولا يرفض تدخلا خارجيا ويرفض
التعاطي مع الخارج ويرفض اعتبار الخارج
جزءا من العمليه في تونس ويرفض اعتبار
السفارات هيئات سياسيه يمكن ان تتحكم
ويمكن ان يكون لها راي ونناقش معها الحلول
وممكنات حل الازمات في تونس وخندقا اخر
يرى بانه يمكن التعاطي مع الخارج ويمكن ان
يكونوا جزءا يعني من الحل ويمكن حتى ان
نفتح معهم الكبريات الملفات للتونسيات
والتونسيين بالنسبه لنا هذوم الخندق زوز
خنادق اللي اللي موجودين
فمن خير العمل السياسي المدني يؤديمقراطي
يعارض 25 جويليه ويعارض رئيس الجمهوريه
كما شاء وله الحق في ذلك فسيكون مرحبا به
في تونس ويمكن اعتباره معارضه وطنيه
ومعارضه حقيقيه نقول له كل احترام لكن كل
من يفتح ابوابه للتعامل مع السفارات وكل
من يحاول ابتزاز الدوله التونسيه ويرفع
التقارير وكل من يحاول التوجه للهيئات
الخارجيه ليجعل من القضيه التونسيه او ما
يسميه بالقضيه التونسيه كقضيه
دوليه تمتز بها الدوله وتمتاز بها الشعب
التونسي فلا يمكن ان يصنف على اساس ان
القوه السياسيه ولا على اساس انه انه
معارضه وفي الرد على من يقول
اننا يمكن لاول مره نعيش تصريحات لوزير
الداخليه بهذا الشكل فاني اذكر بتصريحات
علي العريض لما اتهم الشهيد الرمز شكري
بالعيد بانه هو من يؤجل اوضاع في سليانه
وبعد اشهر يعني يتم اغتيال الرجل كذلك يتم
اغتيال الشهيد محمد الابراهيمي تحت يعني
لما كان علي العريض هو رئيس رئيس الحكومه
حينها نحن
اعتبرنا ان تصريحات على العريض كانت هي
القرار او كانت هي التشريع السياسي
الاغتيال الشهيد شكري بلعيد كذلك راينا
الاختراق الكبير لوزاره الداخليه لما يتم
تسليم الدوله التونسيه لوثيقه من مخابرات
الامريكيه تقول ان هناك سياسي كبير في
تونس وسمته بالاسم محمد رامي سيتم اغتياله
لكن لا تتحرك تتحرك الدوله كذلك
من اجل هذا ومن اجل غيره اعتبرناها عشريه
عشريه سوداء كذلك اذا راينا ان اثنين من
اكبر القضاه في تونس اليوم هم محل تتبعوا
اليوم هم في السجن نحكي للسيد العكرمه
والسيد طيب راشد هم مليون في السجن هذوم
الناس اللي كانت عندهم ابواب الحبس في
تونس اليوم هم محل تتبع ومحل محل مساء لا
يعني العكرمي لما كان قاضي تحقيق في قضيه
شكر بعيده اليوم هو متهم كذلك اقول فتح
السفارات والالتقاء مع السفراء والنقاش
معها في مواضيع وطنيه كلها كانت تكثيف لما
يسمى بالعاشر اليوم نعتقد اننا نحن نخرج
بتونس رويدا رويدا من هذا المستنقع ومن
عشريه عشريه سوداء هناك الكثير من المطبات
هناك الكثير من الاخطاء الاتصاليه قد يكون
هذا صحيح ويجب تداركها لكن سنكون افضل من
ان نكون تحت حكم
المافيات وتحت رعايه يعني السفارات
السفارات والدول والهيئات والجهات المالحه
المفارقه اسمح لي السيد
وليد ان تقريبا ما تقوله هو يظل في
النهايه راي اقليه من الاحزاب بينما
اغلبها واغلب القوى المدنيه والجمعيات ترى
عكس ذلك لكن على كل اريد ان اسال السيد
رياض الشعيبي ونريد ان ان ناخذ منعرج في
النقاش لنتحدث عن ما هو المخرج الكل في
تونس الان يتحدث عن ازمه سياسيه خانقه
ازمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه خانقه وفي نفس
الوقت الرئيس يقول ويكرر باستمرار لا رجوع
الى الخلف وهو على كل يسير بخطن ثابته في
برنامجه ويبدو ان لا احد يستطيع ان يوقف
هذا المسار اذا اردنا ان ننظر الى الى
امكانيه خروج تونس من هذا الوضع كيف تراه
المشكله اليوم انه الازمه في تونس ليست
ازمه سياسيه فقط وليست حتى ازمه اخلاقيه
فقط ولكن هي ايضا في عمقها ازمه اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه
الانقلاب الذي حصل منذ اكثر من سنه ونصف
لم يتراجع فقط عن كل المكاسب والضمانات
القانونيه والحقوقيه التي تحققت للتونسيين
ولكن ايضا دفعها بالبلاد في نفق اخر ربما
اخطر بكثير من النفق السياسي وهو النفق
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي ناهيك ان اليوم
الازمه الاقتصاديه كانت تعصف
بالاستقرار الاجتماعي والسلم الالي في
البلاد
لعل الجميع تابع موقف البنك الدولي بعد
تصريحات العنصريه لصادره عن السلطه تجاه
الافارقه والتي جمد تقريب بمقتضاها
التعامل حكومه التونسيه فيما يتعلق
بالحوار الاستراتيجي التنموي وتاجيل
التاجيلات المتتاليه ايضا لصندوق النقد
الدولي في التعامل مع الحكومه التونسيه
منذ اكتوبر وقع امضاء اتفاق الخبراء ولكن
حتى اليوم ويبدو انه اجتماعات الربيع لم
يبرمج فيها الملف التونسي وربما سنذهب الى
اجتماعات الخريف هل الواقع التونسي
الاجتماعي والاقتصادي سيتحمل مزيد من
الضغط سيتحمل المزيد من
انغلاق الافق سيتحمل المزيد من تازم
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه حتى يحصل
هذا الاتفاق هذا غير مضمون لانه اليوم
الماليه العموميه يعني في اسوا حالاتها
العجز في الميزانيه بارقام يعني غير
مسبوقه انعدام المواد الاساسيه وتقرير
الاخير اللي يقول انه خلال اسابيع او بعض
الاشهر ربما نشهد شحف السي ده ده البنوك
التونسيه وهذا سيكون له اثر كبير جدا طبعا
باعتبار انه نسبه التدين الكبيره التي
قامت بها الحكومه على مستوى الدين الداخلي
بما دفعها لامتصاص اجزاء كبير من السيوله
الموجوده داخل البنوك بالتالي اليوم نحن
نسير
في نفق
ونواجه ازمه متصاعده واذا لم يذعن ولم
تستمع السلطه لنداءات الحوار
والبحث عن الازمه بشكل جماعي والابتعاد عن
خطابات التحريض
والترذيل واتهام المعارضين فاننا لا قدر
الله قد نجد انفسنا في وضع قد لا نستطيع
ان نتقدم بعده بسبب ما يمكن ان يحدث في
البلاد كما قلت من ازمات اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه حاده ما اشرت اليه من تصريحات
الرئيس سعيد فيما يتعلق بالافارقه هنا
اسال السيد مهدي المبروك
كانت اضافه لمواقف اخرى دوليه الان يعني
تونس تقريبا تعيش عزله وعلاقات متوتره مع
الاتحاد الافريقي مع دول الجوار مع
الولايات المتحده اخر تصريحات اليوم مثلا
لمساعده وزيره
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول بان
تونس تسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ تحدثت عن
مناخ من الخوف تحدثت انه الرئيس ياخذ
البلاد الى مسار بعيد جدا عن المسار
الديمقراطي تقريبا تونس تكاد تكون في عزله
مع ازمه اقتصاديه
لا توجد مبادره تقريبا الا مبادره اتحاد
الشغل واتحاد الشغل نفسه في اشكال مع
الحكومه وتقريبا هذه المبادره معروفه
النتيجه
كيف يمكن التعامل مع وضعك هذا
نعم اعت
اولا في مساله الهجره وانا مختص يعني في
قضايا الهجره واساسا تحديدا الهجره
الافريقيه منذ اكثر من 25 سنه واشتغلت مع
العديد من المضمات الدوليه
تقريبا طبعا على المستوى التشريعي لم تحدث
يعني بعد 30 يبرر 2004 اي اصلاحات تشريعيه
لا على قانون الهجره ولا على قانون اللجوء
ولكن بصفه عامه يعني ظلت السلطات التونسيه
تتعامل
فورا تحت ضغط يعني الاتحاد الاوروبي
احيانا تحت بعض من الابتزاز الى غير ذلك
مثل ممارسه ليبيا مثلا الى ولكن لم يصدر
تماما عن السلطات التونسيه خلال اكثر من
ثلاثه عقود مثل هذه التصريحات واعتقد انه
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه ربما يعني بدا يعيي
بشكل متدرج عن الخطا الجزيل في المستوى
الاتصال على الاقل ولكن اعتقد ان الامر
انا في اعتقادي المساله اتصاليه المساله
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه يوم الثلاثاء يوم
الثلاثاء 2020 زار مدينه صفاقس وزاره
مدينه المهديه
وتحدث عن نظريه المؤامره ولم ننتبه وانا
كنت يعني انذاك يعني كتبت على ان الهجره
قضيه مركبه ومعقده ولا علاقه لها
بالمؤامرات الى غير ذلك السيده رئيس
الجمهوريه كما قلت ولم لم يكن مجرد خطا
اتصال وان كان هو خطا اتصالي فعلا ولكن هو
طبعا في اوقيفه
يصدر عن نظريه المؤامره ومساله الشعب
الشعب المتجانس الطاهر الى غير ذلك فحينئذ
الامر لا يعود الى خطا اتصال انما الى
جوهر بنيه
الفكر الشمولي والفكر الشعبي فيما في
اعتقادي يعني الى اين تذهب الامور وهل
هناك انا انا في اعتقادي يعني كان الناس
يعولون على مبادره الاتحاد من ذ اكتوبر
2020 ويبدو ان رئيس الجمهوريه لم يتفاعل
على المبادره ولكن الاتحاد لم
يستحق كما قلت الدروس مبكرا وضل كما قلت
يراهن على ان يقبل الرئيس ولكن
يبدو الان الان ان السيد رئيس وهو يفتح
جميع هذه الجبهات وهذه القدره الرهيبه على
تحويل الاصدقاء والحلفاء الى خصوم وشيطنه
الجميع هذه القدره رهيبه وتتطلب كما قلت
يعني
تتطلب يعني جيشا وبئسا واعتقد انه القدره
على خلق هذه الاجابات المتعدده هي موطن
ولكن بالمقابل وان اكون صريحا معك على ان
كل الجبهات التي فتح الرئيس حقق فيها
انتصارات مؤقته
الجبهه مع القضاه الجبهه مع الحكومه
السابقه الجبهه مع البرلمان الجبهه مع
الجبهه الجبهه مع المعامدين السياسيين
الجبهه مع الاتحاد الجبهه مع الاتحاد
الافريقي هي الجبهه الوحيده التي تراجع
فيها السيد الرئيس واعتقد انه خطابه امس
امام رئيس
غنى بيساو دليل وهي ربما اللحظه الوحيده
وكان مع الخارج هي التي تراجع فيها نسبيا
اما في الداخل فانه يعمل
نعم اتفضل اتفضل اكمل الفكره نعم اعتقد
انه
الان كما كنت نحن نوغل ونحن نذهب الى هذا
السقوط المريع
وهذا العلو الشاهق الذي يقوله الرئيس ربما
للاسف قد يقذف بنا الى سقوط موريه على
مستوى كما كنت على المستوى الخارج وعلى
مستوى الداخل الامر ليست مساله ولكن
المشكل
نحن لا قدر الله ذاهبون
الى لم نلتفت الى بعضنا البعض ولم نتحاور
بالكثير من العقلانيه وبالكثير من
الواقعيه هذا العناد هذا النقطه تحديدا
تشير اليها الان نسال عنها السيد وليد
العباسي
تونس دوله تاريخيا لا تستطيع ان تكون قلعه
قائمه بمفردها معزوله عن العالم تاريخها
مع اوروبا مع دول الجوار مع الافريقي مع
العربي وغيرها الان الرئيس قيس سعيد شان
ام ابينا تقريبا وضع نفسه والبلاد في عزله
هل تعتقد حتى وان كان يريد اقامه نظام
سياسي جديد مثل ما وصفته انت كيف له ان
يقيمه في بلد تقريبا يعني مهدد بالافلاس
حسب المنظمات الدوليه يطمع في قرض باثنين
مليار دولار من من صندوق النقد الدولي
الارجح انه من الصعب ان يحصل عليه في
مناخاتك هذه متوتره اذا الرئيس تقريبا
البلاد نحو المجهول الا تعون ذلك
بالنسبه لنا السيد الكريم نعتقد ان هذا
الارث يعني السيء في على مستوى المديونيه
هذا كل جنيناه من حكم الهوات ومن حكم
الفاسدين طيله عشر سنوات لانه ما جاش من
السنه الماضيه ولا لقبل
يعني موضوع العشريه السوداء كما تسموها
صفحه وطويت الان الرئيس امام استحقاقات لا
يمكن ان نظل نذم في هذه العشريه دون ان
نقدم شيئا يعني الرئيس لم يقدم شيئا للشعب
على مستوى المعيشي والاقتصادي لم يقدم اي
شيء يرفع مستوى المعيشه لم يفتح اي مشروع
ظل فقط يهدم المؤسسات القائمه ويتحدث عن
مؤامرات عمليا لم يقدم شيء يعني كيف كيف
له ان يستمر في بهذا التمشي
سيدي سيدي الكريم ما اعلم جيدا ان مصطلحها
عشريه سوداء قد يزعجك لكن حاول تتحمل هذا
الموقف قليلا على الاقل في ملف التداين
نعتقد ان هناك تراكمات لمده عشر سنوات
تدايره الحكومات كل الحكومات حركه النهضه
والحكومات التي دعمتها حركه النهضه هي من
توجهت الى الجهات المانحه واغرقت الشعب
التونسي وسلمت مفاتيح الدوله التونسيه
للجهات المانحه واليوم نحن نعاني هذا
الملف لكن نعتقد انها فرصه اليوم للدوله
التونسيه في ان تراجع حساباتها في علاقات
مع الغرب في علاقه مع الولايات الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي مع هذه الجهات في ان
تكون لها شركات جديده مبنيه على التوازن
لا على منطقه منطقه التعليمات التي يحاول
او منطق الابتزاز التي تحاول جهه المنحه
فرضه على الشعب التونسي هذا في نقطه اولى
في نقطه ثانيه فيما يتعلق بملف المهاجرين
والهجره الغير نظاميه اعتقد ان السياق هو
الذي جعل من هذا الملف ياخذ ياخذ هذا
البعد الكبير لو ان هذا الخطاب وكلمه رئيس
الجمهوريه كانت قد قيلت في غير هذا السياق
فلن يكون لها مثل هذا هذا الواقع وانا
معكم يعني قلت ان هناك يعني ربما خطا
اتصاليا يحاول رئيس الجمهوريه ووزير
الخارجيه ان يتداركه بالشكل بالشكل
المطلوب لكن جعل نؤكد ودعنا نقول ان
الهجره الغير شرعيه والهجره الغير نظاميه
هي جريمه الاوروبيه ماذا يعني ان الغرب
اليوم في كل ملفاته مسموح له بان يناقش
يعني ترحيل المهاجرين غير الشرعيين وان
يحاول عسكره البحر الابيض المتوسط وان
يحاول ترحيل كل من تطاو يعني اقدامه
اراضيه بحثا عن الطعام وبحثا عن
الامام لكن حين تطرح في تونس ملفات
مجموعات يعني تدفقات كبرى دون وثائق ودون
اقامات حين نطرحها يتم تحويل وجهه
الملف الى منطقي منطق اعتقد السياق وان
هناك بعض من وسائل الاعلام وبعضنا
الاعلاميين يعني حتى انتم سيدي الكريم في
خطابكم مع الامين العام المتحده كنت تريد
استنطاق الرجل لتاخذ منه موقفا من الدوله
التونسي كانت توجيها واضحا منكم والعديد
من المؤسسات الاعلاميه خاصه منها الفرنسيه
في ان توجه وتحاول خنق الموقف الموقف
التونسي فيما يتعلق بالهجره الغير بالهجره
الغير نظاميه نعتقد ان نحن كتونسيات
وكتونسيين نحن ايضا ضحايا مثلنا مثل
اشقائنا من جنوب من ابناء شعبنا في دول
دول الافريقيه وما علينا الا التكاتف
لنرغم هذا الغرب العنصري بان يكفر عن ذنبه
ذنب عشرات يعني سنوات طويله من الاستعمار
وسنوات طويله من الاستغلال والسنوات طويله
من الاستنزاف بان يكفر عن ذنبه ويستثمر في
بلادنا ويستثمر في قناتنا لتكون فعليا
افريقيا
لكن تونس ليست عنصريه لا الدوله التونسيه
عنصريه ولا الشعب التونسي عنصري فقط
خطاب هذا خطاب ثوري
يعني جرب في السابق المشكله ان تونس لا
تستطيع او لا تمتلك
لا لا تمتلك القدره على تحمل تبعات خطاب
من هذا القبيل اسال سيد
رياض الشعيبي الان المعارضه عندما تسالها
عن المخرج تقول رحيل الرئيس قيس سعيد عليه
ان يرحل ويجب ان يسقط الانقلاب ولكن كيف
عمليا لانه عندما ترى الراي العام التونسي
عندما ترى الشارع التونسي اما صامت او لا
يبالي او خائف وبالتالي المعارضه على من
تعول في ازاحه هذا الرئيس
المشكله انه منذ البوادر الاولى للازمه
ومنذ سنتين او اكثر حتى
هناك دعوات متتاليه للحوار من مختلف
الاطراف السياسيه بدايه باتحاد الشغل
ومرورا بالاحزاب السياسيه والقوه السياسيه
ولكن هذا الرئيس وهذه السلطه كانت تعرف
باستمرار عن الاستجابه لهذا المطلب وحتى
بعد الانقلاب كانت الدعوات متتاليه
للحوار واعتبار ان اسقاط الانقلاب والعوده
واستئناف المسار الديمقراطي يمكن ان يتم
عن طريق الحوار ومحاوله ايجاد حلول
للازمات اللي تمر بها البلاد ولكن لما
يئست المعارضه من ان هذه السلطه يمكن ان
تلتجا للحوار كاسلوب لحل الخلافات
السياسيه ولحل الازمه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي تعيش البلاد لم يبقى
امامها الا الضغط من اجل الذهاب
للانتخابات رئاسيه
انتخابات رئاسيه وتشريعيه مبكره الحديث عن
ان الشارع التونسي ربما جزء كبير منه
مازال يساند هذه السلطه طيب هذه حجه علينا
وليست ضدنا بالتالي اذا كانت بالفعل هذه
السلطه تعتقد انها مازالت تحظى بالاغلبيه
لدى شارع التونسي فما عليها الا الاستجابه
لمطلب المعارضه والذهاب لهذه الانتخابات
المبكره ولكن نحن عندما ندعو للانتخابات
مبكره فنحن من منطلق الاحساس ومن منطلق
المعرفه بانقلاب موازين القوى بشكل كبير
جدا وحاله الخوف
والقلق التي يعيشها التونسي اليوم لابد ان
تترجم سياسيا في صناديق الاقتراع من خلال
هذه الانتخابات باعتبار هذا الحد الوحيد
المتبقي للخروج من الازمه الحاليه في
النهايه مع الدكتور مهدي المبروك باختصار
رجاء
الا يخشى انه اذا انسد
ان سدت افاق التغيير السلمي الديمقراطي في
تونس لمعالجه هذه الازمه ان نذهب لا سمح
الله الى احتمالات مخيفه
نعم اعتقد لانه هذا احتمال وارد وان كان
اتمنى لبلادي واتمنى لشعب ان لا نصل الى
مثل هذه
للاسف المخيفه على غرار كما قلت يعني
السيناريو اللبناني وعاده اخرى في افريقيا
واعتقد المخرج الوحيد هو كما قلت اولا هذا
الحوار وهذا النقد الذاتي المتبادل يعني
دون حوار ولذلك الحوار مع المختلفين
فليسمح لسوليده لا نختلف مع مع من يتطابق
معنا نحن الحوار يعني حتى يعني فلسفه
الحوار كما نظر له
الحوار هو هذه القدره على ان تصبر على من
يختلف معك اذا ذهبنا كما قلت الى حوار
والى نقد متبادل فانوس نجدها اما اذا كما
قلت يعني استبد من العناد وكما قلت ذهبنا
الى هذا الت فانا للاسف هذه السيناريوات
ربما ربما لم تعد مستبعد يعني سيناريو
الافلاس وسيناريو هذا العنف المعمم وهذا
الانفجار ولذلك انا قلت دائما نعول على
لحظه العقل لحظه المصارحه من اجل انقاذ
بلادي مكافه هذه الوارده جدا شكرا جزيلا
لك مهدي المبروك شكرا ايضا وليد العباسي
شكرا لك ايضا رياض الشعيبي بهذا المشاهدين
الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد باذن الله الاسبوع
المقبل مع سيناريوهات جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]